- People may look down on these things
like a dandelion flower or cattails.
They're like, "This is
just some common weed.
"How can this be used by
Michelin star restaurants?"
And I think that's what's changing.
People wanna go back to things
that are sort of raw.
(upbeat music)
My name is Tama Matsuoka
Wong, and I'm a forager.
When I first hear the word forager,
I didn't really know what it meant.
But then I found out
that it's sort of like
doing a dance with nature and finding
the secret foods in the wild.
Most of the restaurants I work with
are Michelin star restaurants,
such as Gramercy Tavern,
restaurant Daniel,
Cosme, and a number of others.
I came from a different background.
I didn't study horticulture.
I didn't study botany.
I went to Harvard Law School,
and I practiced a career
for decades in investment banking.
I always liked nature;
I always liked food.
I was a failed gardener so I
was trying to find good recipes
for my weeds that I found
out were good to eat.
So, people just started
asking me for this.
I started getting more and more involved.
It was super creative, impactful,
and it just took me.
Most of the stuff that I
get is from around my house
but you, you could find
common weeds anywhere.
Probably I deal with between four
and 500 different plants a year.
Some of my favorite ingredients are sumac,
wild brassica, I like wild
shiso, and cattail shoots.
People don't realize that all the stuff
around them is good food.
In two meters of ground, you
could have 50 different plants.
Fifty, and that's nature.
It can be something
amazing that you can enjoy,
and you don't even have
to go too far to get it.
When I first started bringing my weeds
to very elevated restaurants...
- Oh, wow, that's beautiful.
- [Tama] I didn't know you're
supposed to call chefs, Chefs
because I'm just a forager.
- Well, the thing I love is that the chefs
just see the huge beauty
in every of these plants.
They love them like they're little jewels.
And I don't feel like it's my product;
I feel like it's nature's product
and that they respect the plant.
So, it's a huge bond.
It's not about the chef or me.
It's about the plant.